[Musique]
visiter les archives de québec s'est
littéralement remonter l'histoire de la
ville le passé de la capitale santa
s'ils s'y ranger soigneusement dans une
de ces trente mille boîtes des millions
de petits documents qui dessine la
grande aventure de québec
en consultant les procès verbaux on veut
savoir comment les grandes décisions ont
été prises les orientations comment la
ville ont évolué au fil du temps c'est
vraiment une mine d'informations le très
très riches les archives de québec
remonte à ce document signé par le roi
soleil lui-même en 588 le général de
gaulle winston churchill
autant de personnages qui ont marqué
l'histoire avec un grand h mais qui ont
aussi écrit à leur manière
celle de québec par les témoignages
qu'on voit souvent en bas des photos où
l'on voit la reconnaissance qu'ils ont
eu l'heur de leur passage et québec est
une ville effectivement de peut-être un
petit gabarit versus des grandes
métropoles de ce monde mais on a une
histoire riche et pertinente et on évite
l'estrien à découvrir la ville misent
sur le numérique pour rendre les
archives plus accessible plus de 70000
fiche historiques sont déjà disponibles
gratuitement sur internet c'est une
façon de garantir aux citoyens l'accès à
ces archives en attendant retournent
dans leur nouvel écrin dans une
bibliothèque gabrielle roy rénové on va
voir une salle qui vont être
effectivement un peu plus petit mais
plus orienté pour l'exposition de pièces
la mise en valeur de
de nos documents de nom
image de de l'année de l'histoire de la
ville de québec
une histoire riche comme celle de québec
méritent d'être exposés attention par
contre pour les plus nostalgiques
plongée dans le passé peut parfois
ravivé les souvenirs douloureux ici
sébastien tanguay radio canada à québec